hey there and welcome to this course on
CSS variables so why do you wanna learn
CSS variables well first of all because
in CSS
you very often end up in situations like
this where you have for example a main
red color throughout your app which you
are using at multiple places and the old
way of doing that would simply be to
reuse the same hexadecimal value like
that however with CSS variables you're
able to declare it as a variable first
and then use that variable wherever you
want later on and the obvious benefit
here is that now you can simply update
this value here and these two will be
automatically updated and also it
semantically it makes more sense it's
easier to see that yeah this title is
red than it is to see that this title
here is red unless you can parse
hexadecimal values quickly in your head
and some of you might say that well I've
had less and sass variables for years so
what's new with CSS variables well first
of all it's easier to get started this
is native to the browser so you need no
transpiling which is pretty nice
secondly CSS variables have access to
the Dom so you can create local scopes
meaning CSS variables that only work in
a certain section of your app for
example you can also change the
variables with JavaScript which is
really handy for example if you want to
enable your users to let's say change
the font size of your page and it's also
ideal for responsiveness as you can
change variables for example based upon
media queries and neither of these use
cases which I'll show you later would be
possible with less and sass and finally
as we'll see it's perfect for themes and
by that I don't necessarily mean themes
as in your website visitors being able
to change the layout with component
specific themes for example for items
which you want to change a little bit
could be a product after it has been
added to a shopping cart or an or an
article you want to feature or whatever
it basically it's a very common use case
and CSS variables make it really easy
and throughout this course you'll become
a CSS variables master in eight
screencasts and they're pretty quick I
explain my goal with this course is to
get you up to speed as quickly as
possible
there are also some interactive
challenges or I will at least challenge
you to jump into the code and perform
tasks in some of the costs and there's a
Q&A section in each of the costs so feel
free to ask questions there and I will
try to reply as best as I can or
sometimes other people actually also
reply and that's great
if you see a question and you know the
answer feel free to help other people
out as that's great for your karma
finally this is me I'm a front-end
developer and a co-founder of this site
scrim ba you can reach out to me via
Twitter if you want or feel free to join
our Gator chatroom if you have any
comments or questions so finally this is
the project we'll be working on
throughout this course so you'll get
very familiar with this here is the
mark-up and in the index dot CSS the CSS
which we'll be working with in the next
screencast you'll create your very first
CSS variable so I'll see you there
pe in this screencast you're going to
learn how to create your very first CSS
variable so here we have an example of a
portfolio website it consists of a
navbar a main section with some items
and then a footer and this is what we'll
be working with throughout this course
the CSS is defined here or at least the
CSS that we care about I've also added a
bunch of styling in the basic dot CSS
file but that styling won't be relevant
for what you're going to learn in this
course so I've extracted out the CSS we
want to work with just to make it easier
for us the markup is defined here in the
index.html and that's just
straightforward HTML so let's not which
I'm not going to explain as I'm assuming
that you are familiar with HTML so we
have three different colors so as you
can see we have three different colors
on our portfolio website it's the red
which is our default text color the
beige background and the yellow color
for the items here and as you can see
from the CSS we're reusing the
hexadecimal values quite a few places
we're setting the main red color here
and we're also setting it explicitly on
the paragraph an h1 tag and I'll tell
you why a bit later in the course and
also on the anchor tags and the
background of the button and whenever
you see a CSS value being reused like
this it's a perfect example for
introducing CSS variables so let's do
that
we'll start by defining our variable and
then we first have to decide which scope
we want the variable to live in we'll
choose the route would you say
pseudo-class that points to the root
element in the document in our case that
is the HTML element itself and when we
defined it on the top-level element like
that the variables we declare inside
here will be available throughout the
entire app it'll be a so-called global
variable to define it will do - - red
then
simply copy this value here like that we
can now use this variable through this
weird syntax or and - - read and this
might seem a little bit strange with the
two dashes and the bar and then passing
in the variable but that's just how the
spec is written so you have to do it
like this two dashes when you declare a
variable and use it and always use var
otherwise it won't work
so let's reuse this movie all the places
where we're using the red color here
here and down here so now let's do the
same thing with the beige background
even though that's now just being used
one place here now I still think we
should put it in a variable as it also
makes the code easier to read so let's
do - - age and copy this value base it
in here and then replace this with var -
- beige so I think we start to see the
benefit here already we don't have to
repeat ourselves again and again and the
code here is actually more
understandable and if we were simply
using the hexadecimal values as this
here as the variable names allows you to
quickly glance over the code and
understand okay yeah so the color of the
h1 and the P tags is indeed red and then
there's also the obvious benefit that if
we want to change the value for example
just our red color a little bit then we
can simply change the value of the red
variable I happen to have a different
shade of red on my clipboard so I'll
paste that in and as you can see that
updated the red color is Ralph the
entire app so let's get back to the old
one like that okay what I want you to do
now is to take our third color the
yellow color which is used here and here
and create a variable
do it on the root element and then use
it down here so pause the screencast
jump into the code and do that and when
you're finished just resume back to this
screencast and then I'll do it as well
so go ahead and do that now as I think
it's really important for you to
actually get your hands dirty with the
code okay hopefully you managed to do
the tasks now I'm going to do it so
we'll create a yellow variable and we'll
grab the color value here and then we
can replace value here with var - -
yellow and we can do the exact same
thing down here and okay so that was it
I'll see you in the next screencast
heyyyyyy in this screencast we're going
to learn how to override variables
because in the previous one you learned
how to create variables on the root
element which points to the root element
in our document which is this HTML tag
here and CSS variables works so that all
the children of the element in which you
declare the variable on have access to
that variable and as our entire markup
on the page is a descendant of the HTML
tag our CSS variables were available
throughout the entire application
whether there might be cases where you
for example want the variables to change
a little bit in certain sections of the
app and that's where overriding comes in
which is really handy and not something
something you can do with sass and less
variables as they know nothing of the
Dom where CSS variable does so you can
tell a CSS variable that you want the
value to change for example inside the
given element and we're gonna do that in
the items because here we want our cause
here we want our red color to be a
little bit softer now actually added the
new value down here so I'm gonna copy
that and inside of the item will do the
exact same thing as we did up in the
root will simply do - - red and we'll
paste in its value and now you can see
that the red color inside the items
changed nots happening here is that the
h1 tag which is using the red variable
and the button which is also using the
red variable for its background now has
a red variable which refers to the
updated value since they are inside of
the item let's have a look at that in
the HTML here is the item elements you
can see it has an h1 wrapped inside of
it and a button as well and inside of
each of these items we've flipped the
the red variable from this value up here
to this value down here and the red
variable is inherited down to its
children so all the elements inside
the items get their read variables
updated as well that's a really neat
thing that the variables are inherited
down in the documentary notice though
that for the h1 tag up here which as we
can see is outside of the divs with the
class of item the red value is still the
original one up here okay so that was it
I'll see you in the next screencast
II in this screencast we're going to do
almost the same thing as we did in the
previous one where we overruled variable
in a local scope however this time we're
going to create a new variable in a
local scope and this is relevant for
cases where you know that the variable
will only be used in that section of the
app so it's no need putting it in the
global scope here up in the root but for
example say that we want the red color
in our nav bar to have a different shade
than it has throughout the app what we
then can do is that on the nav bar let's
target it not bar agree create a new
variable just as we do it in the root by
doing - - let's call it nav red then
let's paste this value in actually and
just change it a little bit I'm gonna
remove this 6 and add 1 that should make
it a bit different though still pretty
red and then down in the anchor tags in
the nav bar where we previously referred
to the global red variable we're now
going to refer to the nav red there as
you can see the color changed through
more red orange-ish color and now this
nav red is only available in the nav bar
which is the mark up here meaning that
only the children inside this element
can access the nav red variable so if I
now try to use this nav red variable
outside of the nav bar that's for
example try down in the button make the
background use the nav red you can see
that just broke the layout because
Navarrete doesn't exist down here there
only exists inside here so what I want
you to do now is create a local variable
inside of the item you can for example
call it item yellow and then use that
yellow inside of the items so go ahead
and do that pause the screencast create
a new variable in the item and then Ryu
and then use that variable somehow
inside of the items
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
now I'll show you how to do this well
it's really simple simply do - - item
yellow and then set the value to this
here let's modify it a little bit let's
swap out this C with an F that should
change it substantially now we'll use
the item yellow here ok this and paste
it in and boom you can see the yellow
color inside here is updated however
inside of the button we're still
referring to the global yellow
so let's paste that in there as well and
there it's starting to look good or
early depending on your design
preferences finally I'm gonna point out
that some people prefer to separate the
declaration of variables and the
reference so what you could do then is
take this one and remove it and then I
can and then paste it in there so now
we're declaring it here and referencing
it down here and that's basically a
matter of personal preferences as you
can do whatever you want okay
how's it so I'll see you in the next
screencast
hey in this screencast we're going to
talk about themes as that's an area
where CSS variables come in really handy
and you might think well I'm not going
to allow my users to switch themes on my
site anyway so why do I need to learn
this well I'm not just talking about
user specific themes but also component
specific themes and that's a much more
normal use case for example could be
that you want to mark an item in your
ecommerce store as purchased or added to
cart or could be that you have a section
of your site may be an admin section
which has a different theme perhaps it's
darker than the website itself or as we
were going to do perhaps you want to
feature something on your site and by
simply giving the item a featured class
make it stand out from the rest that's
what we're going to do here now we want
to simply be able to add a featured
class to one of these items and thereby
make it stand out from the rest we
basically want to be able to do like
this feature which should result in a
style change for both the div here
itself and the h1 and buttons and
normally in order to do this you'd have
to create a featured class and then also
target the button and also be a drunk
tank you result in quite a lot of extra
CSS in order to achieve that but the
beautiful thing we'll see is as
variables is that you can scrap all this
and inside of this featured class here
we're simply going to change the value
of a few variables
we're going to override them which we
learned in the previous screencast I've
cheated a little bit and copied in the
new values for yellow and red in here
and simply paste that in and boom as you
can see now this project D item stands
out from the other items it's not a
particularly nice color but it proves
the point what happens here is that the
h1 which is inside of featured now
refers to the red value which we have
declared here and not the red value in
the
up here and also the button it's red and
yellow now refer to the local values for
red and yellow now I can add feature to
this item right here as well for example
run the code and you can see now both of
these are featured so technically we're
just doing the same thing that we did in
the screencast where we were overriding
variables however now we've put it in a
more useful context okay that was it
I'll see you in the next screencast
hey in this screencast we're going to
learn how to work with CSS variables in
JavaScript because as I've mentioned
before CSS variables live in the Dom
meaning that you can update them with
JavaScript that's super cool not
something you could do with for example
sass or less variables as they are
transpiled down to regular CSS so let's
head over to the index dot J's
and the first thing we need to do is to
grab hold of the root which is where we
declared the variables you can see here
and that now refers to the HTML as that
is the root of our document so du bar
dot where we flexure then grab the root
let's log that out as you can see our
logs out in the HTML element itself to
get the Styles we've defined on root
goo-goo of our root styles and then
usually get computed style method which
we have access to and which returns the
properties and values for the element we
pass in and passing and then to get one
of the variables let's for example grab
the red one will do group styles drop
get property value and then simply pass
in the name of the variable which is red
now console log out red you'll see that
we get the correct value can see this
one here so now that we know that we can
fetch the variable let's also change it
that refer to the root iam root I'll set
prop property and then the first
parameter is the name of the variable
Lucas - that red and the second one is
whatever we want to update it to so
let's just change it from the sake of
this tutorial through green
runner cold and boom as you can see
entire page has been updated as we've
simply change this hair and it's
inherited down to all the elements which
is using it throughout this app so this
is super useful just imagine that you
for example want your users to change
the font size on the page or maybe you
actually want them to be able to pick
themes or change colors at some in some
sections CSS variables make that really
easy for you okay what I want you to do
now is to fetch this yellow color here
which we are using in the background for
the items fetch it out using javascript
and change it to something else for
example to orange so go ahead and do
that and when you come back I'll do it
as well okay hopefully you managed to do
the task it's really simple all we have
to do is in order to fetch this yellow
color here is simply change the red to
yellow instead it's also strangely
probably resist yellow like that and
then let's set it to orange and there we
go we've changed the yellow variable to
orange and that effects not only the
background of the items themselves as it
uses the yellow variable but also the
text color inside of the button and both
of them are now orange okay now is it
I'll see you in the next screencast
Hey in the screencast I'm going to teach
you how to change a variable based upon
the width of the screen cuz shrink the
screen down to a typical mobile with the
items become too wide for the screen so
we need to rearrange on our grid we want
them to rather appear on top of each
other so stacked downwards and to do
that you have to learn a little bit
about CSS grid as well because I'm
pulled in the grid styling just the
styling for the grid and actually have a
full CSS grid course which I've linked
to in the About section in the
screencast so be sure to check that one
out as well and if you haven't seen CSS
grid before it's pretty straightforward
but what we're saying here is that our
element with the class of grid which is
the grid here which wraps these four
items let's do like this so this one
here it's getting a display of grid and
we're defining the columns here we're
saying that we want two columns each
being 200 pixels wide so these two
columns are 200 pixels wide each and
grid auto rows means that the rows will
be 140 pixels tall so we're setting that
here and grid gap sets the gap in
between the items and justify content
Center basically centers the content so
check out my grid course if you think
this is hard but you don't really need
to understand this all you need to
understand is this line here which is
saying that we want two columns each
being 200 pixels wide because that's
what we need to change with with our
media query meaning that we need to
extract this out in a variable and I
actually like to declare my variables at
the top so have have it like this
variable declarations and then of the
styles here so that we separate cool and
here will be grid and paste in grid
panel columns but we'll change this to
columns and then when we're using that
value to just have to do var - - columns
like that so this should be pretty
straightforward for you by now we're
declaring a variable and we're using it
now let's change it when the width of
the screen becomes less than 450 pixels
video oh and Max width:450px and you
might be fool to think that you could
just do like this columns 200px as
that's the change we want we want to
remove one of the columns where we have
two columns each pin 200 pixels you want
to reduce that to one which basically
results in the items stacking on top of
each other however we can't just change
it here we have to wrap it in the scope
in which we defined it the grid like
that there so at the width which is
below 450 px we're going to change the
columns variable inside of grid to 200px
instead of 200px 200px let's try that
will narrow the screen and boom as you
can see now they're stacked on top of
each other and this isn't something that
you could have done with less or sass
variables as they have no information of
what's going on in the Dom they're
already transpiled down to regular CSS
remember ask these CSS variables live in
the dom they've access to this and you
can change them based upon for example
screen resize or screen size in general
now what I want to do is also change the
background the base color when the
screen is less than 450 px so jump into
the code and try to do that and when you
come back I'll show you how to do it as
well okay so hopefully you managed to do
the task changing the base color
and do that have to refer to the route
again and page and then giving you value
let's copy this and paste it in and
change it a little bit run the code and
then when we shrink in the page boom you
can see that the background also changed
okay does it I'll see you in the next
screencast
Hey in this screencast I want to talk a
little bit about inheritance as you as
you've seen throughout this course CSS
variables behave very much as other CSS
properties in that their values are
inherited and cascade
however there are a few things that you
maybe would think that would work but
which doesn't and I want to explain
rules to in this screencast well the
first one is that you can create
variables based upon other variables
let's say that for example all one
variable main color and we wanted to
simply be the red color now we can refer
to main color instead of red for example
down here in the anchor tags in the nav
bar let's do that they are still red now
and here you might be fool to think that
you could be like this and update the
red or override the red variable here to
something else that's just it's just
painted orange instead for example and
you could expect that that would
override the red which again would
override main color but as you can see
that isn't happening because main color
the value of that has already been
resolved to the value of red so main
color doesn't have a reference to the
variable it only points to the value
however if you were to rather update the
main color here like that as you can see
then it works so that's something you
should be aware of and the second thing
is that we've here set the color of the
age wants and the paragraphs to read
specifically and you don't actually need
this we could have just taken this way
and the page would look identical
however if you now work for example
update the
read value here hmm let's take new
orange hairs well then you can see that
the aged one isn't updated and that's
because it has inherited the 8r on the
color red from the body though it's
lower is only inherited the value of the
variable doesn't inherit the variable
itself so again it's this about
referencing the value or the variable
and we have to explicitly tell it to
reference the variable in order to be
able to then change the h1 tag with this
overriding hair now you can see it is
indeed orange so I hope that wasn't too
confusing if it was feel free to ask any
questions in the Q&A section and I'll
reply